[Musique]
elle est refoulée vous plains ces
produits oubliés mais les rendre médical
apparaissent ainsi place à la
connaissiez il faut dire que les audaces
de cette fois nous habitons possiblement
[Musique]
se veut bouger mes pieds sont les
tessons de bouteille c'est pas mal je ne
sens rien du tout et c'est ma tante que
cette idée pendant la guerre le
pratiquait déjà ce métier on a eu l'idée
de le reprendre et ce afin que j'ai
autour du cou sont des bois sont pas
dangereux par leur piqûre carrez n'en
possèdent pas ce délai tout seulement et
toronto elle ne va pas c'est assez rare
quand même moi c'est vraiment étonnant
c'est moins simple à gérer autant de ces
coupés ou en euros - pour un moineau
remettre certains visiteurs oui me pose
des questions devaient dans le si je me
coupe ou si ça me fait du mal
oh non je suis insensible même
sensiblement
venez voir le pied sur le vide elle
était le cadet des tisanes ou cinq ans
dix huit et dix corps et des jambes
et pourtant les billets 10 entre les
villes dans cet essai était finie se
décide à tenter sans corde et enterré
comment vous déplacez vous dans une
boîte aménagé on me transporte dans une
pub et je pèse 3 kg 300 g 22 ans
pourquoi régime alimentaire particulier
non je suis heureux aux perfusions dans
mon embryons
aucune est ce que votre position est pas
un petit peu instable non allez tous
retrouvés bien comme ça oui et non vous
auriez aimé avoir accord
oui pourquoi ben si je vois des gens qui
t'ont décor déshabillez moi
restivo public j'hérite à la jeune fille
la plus grosse du monde
264 kg 528 livre personne de l'intérieur
génère davantage représentés
rita la jeune fille la plus grosse du
monde rieter est de nationalité
italienne
à sa naissance elle peser dit qu'il doit
à l'heure actuelle âgé seulement de 33
ans
elle pèse du 164 kg 528 livre je dire
tout particulièrement notre attention
c'est dire le fait d'émettre 30 de tour
de taille m et 1,62 touré cuisse et bien
si la même et l'appareil chaussures
humaine
combien valent des 100 points richard se
doper sous pour aller danser
[Musique]